[Music]
breaking news this Monday night sudden
resignation
why Newfoundland and Labrador s premier
has abruptly called it quits what did
the Prime Minister accomplish in his
emergency meeting about those rail
blockades plus fresh fears about how
they could drive up food prices growing
frustration on a cruise ship and why
others who got the all-clear are told to
get back under quarantine and a money
idea how Terry Fox is in the running
uses ero
to be the face of Canada's five-dollar
bill
global national with Donna freezin Robin
Gill good evening and thank you for
joining us we begin with breaking news
from Newfoundland and Labrador tonight
after just over four years in power
Dwight ball is stepping down as premier
of the province tonight I am announcing
that my time in politics is coming to an
end it's time for me to spend more time
with my family and friends in Deer Lake
to live a more private life our Atlantic
correspondent Ross Lord has been
speaking to his sources and joins us now
Ross the premier was facing a leadership
review was this a pre-emptive move on
his part I think it's a fair question
Robin because there have always been
rumblings that members of balls caucus
were unhappy with them and we know from
our sources that there are plenty of
people who want his job caucus members
or other people with liberal connections
and ball has also been dogged by
scandals over a big patronage
appointment and by finances the crushing
provincial debt and also the massive
overrun for the Muskrat Falls hydro
project construction Newfoundlanders and
Labradorians feared that to pay that
overspending back their electrical rates
were going to go through the roof and
just last week Baal and the federal
government announced the plan to keep
the lid on power rates the timing of
that announcement tonight as part of
ball's legacy makes more sense Ross how
does this play out with the federal
Liberal government in Ottawa well it's
interesting because Trudeau and Bal
their political careers have sort of
paralleled each other in some ways ball
one that big majority in 2015 in the
afterglow of Trudeau's big victory and
the fortunes of both leaders took the
hit last year when the federal and
Newfoundland liberals were both knocked
down to minority status when ball came
to power he became one of seven liberal
premiers today only Newfoundland and
Labrador and Nova Scotia are run by
provincial liberals ball does say he'll
continue to represent his riding on the
provinces west coast until the next
election which in a minority could
happen pretty much any time and if power
does change hands that will present yet
another potential challenge for Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau
raus Lord thanks prime minister justin
trudeau called an emergency meeting
today to help put an end to anti
pipeline blockades that have shut down
much of canada's rail system the
government group discussed the dispute
over a natural gas pipeline that crosses
with so itand territory in Houston BC 20
First Nations band councils that are
elected agreed to the 6.6 billion dollar
670 kilometer coastal gasoline pipeline
but some of the elders of the what's
owed to nation aren't on side arguing
they hold authority over the traditional
lands they'd been protesting in the area
for months then the RCMP began enforcing
an injunction to clear the way for
construction in solidarity
demonstrations have been flaring up all
over the country most notably in
southern Ontario in Mohawk territory
near Belleville so how did southern
Ontario become a flashpoint
it's a busy rail corridor and service
has been stopped cold stalling the
nation's economy as our chief political
correspondent David akin reports despite
Trudeau's urgent meeting it's still not
clear how or when the blockades will
come down Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
arrived in his Parliament Hill office
for an urgent cabinet committee meeting
they had one task find a way to bring
down the barricades that have all but
brought Canada's rail network to a halt
but minutes after starting the meeting
on bringing blockades down a new one
went up at a US border crossing in
Eastern Ontario protesters in southern
Manitoba had the same idea trying to
shut down the main north-south link to
America in Toronto a noisy protest
against oil pipelines
[Music]
even though the pipeline at the center
of this dispute is for natural gas
meanwhile this rail blockade near
Belleville Ontario has been up for more
than 10 days it has forced Via Rail to
cancel more than 400 trains affecting
more than 83,000 passenger rail
blockades elsewhere in Ontario in
Manitoba and NBC have disrupted Canada's
Freight system just off the coast of
Vancouver a fleet of ships waits to
offload cargo that has nowhere to go see
and rail handed out 450 layoff notices
Sunday and it's Union worries that
number could rise to 6000 by week's end
and a new worry in all of this a
potential hike in food prices because of
higher freight costs we may not
experience shortages but there'll be
more financial pressures put on
distributors to actually keep costs down
hence that urgent cabinet meeting back
on Parliament Hill and yet as he left
Monday's meeting the Prime Minister
could not say when or how those economy
stalling blockades would be lifted
I understand how worrisome this is for
so many Canadians and difficult for many
people and families across the country
we're going to continue to focus on
resolving this situation quickly and
peacefully and that's what we're going
to do and as the economic pressure
mounts the political temperature is
about to rise as well MPs return to
Ottawa Tuesday after a week back in the
writings and these blockades and the
economic disruption they are causing are
certain to dominate the agenda Robin
David akin in Ottawa and one last note
Via Rail announced late today it has
cancelled all operations until the end
of the day Wednesday with the exception
of Sudbury White River and Churchill the
PAS not all resource projects with
indigenous communities in Canada are
getting derailed the Quebec government
and the Cree Nation have agreed to a
major long-term deal Premier France
while ago and the James Bay Cree have
signed a four point seven billion dollar
agreement that will extend rail lines
north and protected new wildlife
habitats over the next 30 years Legault
says the project also known as the grand
alliance
we'll help curb greenhouse gas emissions
from diesel trucks there's another big
shake-up at Bombardier with a deal to
sell its Trane division the montreal
based company will offload its rail
business to French train giant Alstom
the agreement is worth more than eight
billion dollars u.s. it will narrow
bombarde days focus to private jets and
help pay down the company's debt load of
more than nine billion dollars for
decades Bombardier has received billions
of dollars in subsidies from both
federal and provincial levels of
government some welcome news tonight for
Canadians stuck on board a coronavirus
stricken cruise ship in Japan the
federal government says a plane is now
enroute to pick them up and bring them
home meanwhile there's a scramble to
track down Canadians from another cruise
ship after an American passenger tested
positive for the virus here's Heather
York's West the streets of this normally
bustling cambodian town have become
unusually quiet tourism had already
taken a hit in recent months now another
blow just days after the community
welcomed the more than 1400 passengers
of the MS Western M there is news that
one of those passengers has tested
positive for köppen 19 obviously we're
working very closely with the ship's
manifest to try and understand who who
has been traveling from that particular
that particular ship and what their
travel path is 271 Canadians had been
onboard the ship
some of those passengers have reportedly
already made their way back home we're
working right now to try and understand
which Canadians have left the ship and
what their travel routes are and we'll
have more to say as we understand that
circumstance meanwhile Canadians
quarantined aboard another cruise ship
the diamond princess are preparing to
come home late Monday afternoon Canada's
foreign affairs minister confirmed via
Twitter that a government chartered
flight was on its way to Tokyo and that
Canadians aboard the ship who were not
ill could expect to fly home Tuesday
more than 450 people aboard the ship
have tested positive for the virus
including at least 15 Canadians more
than 300 American cruise ship passengers
arrived back in the u.s. early Monday
where they will be kept isolated for 14
days
military bases in Texas in California
when they finally arrived home Canadian
evacuees will be isolated as well at the
NAB Canada Training Institute in
Cornwall Ontario an exhausting prospect
for those who have already been
quarantined for 13 days and Counting
just tired how about your ex West Global
News Calgary in China authorities are
considering more precautions as covin 19
spreads with millions of people still in
lockdown officials are now reportedly
weighing whether to delay one of the
country's most important political
gatherings of the year a government
spokesperson told chinese state media
that delaying the annual parliamentary
meeting would give the communist
government more time to get the
situation under control since the
outbreak began Chinese officials say
more than 1,800 people have died and as
of today the total number of cases sits
at more than 73,000 Chinese officials
insist there are positive signs they say
the daily number of new cases appears to
be going down but the World Health
Organization says it's too early to know
if the worst is over this trend must be
interpreted very cautiously trends can
change as new populations are affected
it's too early to tell if this reported
decline will continue every scenario is
still on the table in Japan there is so
much concern over the spread of Kovan 19
drastic steps are being taken to reduce
crowds in public spaces organizers of
the Tokyo marathon typically one of the
biggest races in the world say they're
restricting the event to only elite
runners and public birthday celebrations
for the Emperor of Japan have been
canceled the event in Tokyo typically
draws tens of thousands of people in
Hong Kong there's another sign of the
growing panic over the outbreak
police say armed robbers tried to steal
hundreds of rolls of toilet paper
outside a supermarket over the last few
weeks coronavirus concerns a fuel to run
on toilet paper and stores have
struggled to keep their shelves stocked
in today's case police say the stolen
supply was recovered a short time
to the theft and two men were arrested
there is an about-face tonight from the
New Brunswick government on health care
reforms it announced last week the
province will now keep overnight
hospital emergency services the
cash-strapped government has discovered
there's a high price to pay for trying
to save health care dollars once again
here's Ross Lord for New Brunswick
premier Blaine Higgs declaring a
healthcare crisis is easy an aging
demographic coupled with a growing labor
force shortage is hampering our ability
to provide the right care in the right
place at the right time the hard part is
finding solutions last week the
government announced unprecedented
measures a plan to close six hospital
emergency departments during overnight
hours moving doctors and other staff to
daytime shifts when there's more demand
suddenly the premier is backing off I
can't in good conscience move forward
without addressing the concerns and
fears that have been brought to light
Higgs says the affected communities had
more questions than health authorities
could answer now instead of using family
day to protest the cuts people are
expressing relief we need our lab some
senior Brunswick's about face as a
lesson to other parts of Canada as they
look to improve or at least maintain
their health care I think what they can
learn is at any time they're looking at
serious change that's going to affect
people their lives they have to realize
all the factors you know the the
politics of it the money of it but also
people's genuine fears and emotions that
they're worried about themselves they're
worried about their loved ones since
Thursday New Brunswick's Progressive
Conservative government lost the support
of two key MLAs including deputy premier
Robert Govan who resigned from the party
with their minority government in danger
of being toppled Higgs now says he'll
consult with communities over the spring
and summer suggesting any changes won't
happen for a while a new position for a
would be health care reform ur who is
now in retreat
Ross Laura Global News how
facts the race to the White House has a
newcomer surging ahead coming up how
Mike Bloomberg is selling himself as the
one to defeat Donald Trump plus up up
and away the buzz over this historic
flight he was late to the race but Mike
Bloomberg has quickly become too big to
ignore the former New York City Mayor is
using his personal fortune to mount a
campaign to unseat Donald Trump but
first he'll have to win the Democratic
nomination as Jackson prosecco explains
the billionaire's deep pockets are
making him a surprise contender he's the
other wealthy New Yorker running for
president how we doing and Mike
Bloomberg intends to give Donald Trump
or run for his money
mr. president you can't bully me and I
won't let you bully the American people
Bloomberg has put his sixty-two billion
dollar fortune where his mouth is I'll
build an economy that delivers good jobs
flooding the airwaves with ads that he
paid for Mike will get it done
shaking up the crowded race for the
Democratic nomination he thinks he can
buy this election well I Got News for
mr. Bloomberg and that is the American
people are sick and tired of
billionaires buying elections to the
chagrin of the other candidates
Bloomberg has already rocketed up to
third place in the polls without ever
joining a debate or appearing on a
ballot I think he cannot hide behind the
airwaves and the money
what Bloomberg is really selling is his
ability to get under Donald Trump's skin
look he's a lightweight he's a
lightweight you're gonna find that out
he's also one of the worst debaters I've
ever seen and his presence is zero the
ways you can tell is that if he's
worried if he mentions you and he's a
narcissist the billionaire is an
unlikely choice for a Democratic Party
that has moved to the left
he's a former Republican and is still
under fire for his time as mayor of New
York when he promoted a police policy
known as stock
than frisk that targeted people of color
apologized for the practice and the pain
that it caused but Democrats may be
willing to look past that if they think
he can beat Trump Bloomberg is betting
it's that simple
I can understand voters who are looking
at Michael Bloomberg saying okay well
good we won't have to worry about that
with him he's willing to spend what it
takes to defeat this guy he'll appear on
the ballot for the first time in 14
states on Super Tuesday a test of
whether his expensive outsider campaign
has earned him the trust of Democrats
Jackson prosecco Global News Washington
still ahead the jet man who will have
your imagination soaring
you are watching global national boats
have replaced cars on major roads in
parts of England and Wales storm dennis
has prompted five severe flood alerts
and the government is warning there's a
danger to life a month's worth of rain
fell over the weekend damaging thousands
of homes and businesses at least three
people have died
Prime Minister Boris Johnson says he has
no plans to visit the flooded areas in
Jackson Mississippi neighborhoods are
under water the Pearl River crested at
just over 11 meters this morning that's
the third highest level ever recorded
for this body of water several hundred
homes have been damaged and a state of
emergency remains search and rescue
crews responded to 16 calls for help
over the past couple of days more rain
is on its way tonight and water levels
aren't expected to recede for days what
we are about to show you might make you
believe people can fly vince perfet from
france blasted off with a complex carbon
wing developed by a team of
international engineers the technology
powered by four mini jet engines allowed
rafet to go as high as 1,800 meters and
even perform a mid-air loop the stunt
was done as part of Dubai's Expo 2020
up next the push to add a Canadian hero
to your wallet
move over sir wilfrid laurier
the Bank of Canada wants to put a new
face on the $5 bill it's now taking
nominations to name the next notable
Canadian the list includes prominent
politician Tommy Douglas hockey hero Tim
Horton and even beloved actor John Candy
but there is a big push for another
revered Canadian a city in DC is
promoting his hometown hero Terry Fox
and as Mike Armstrong explains the
timing couldn't be better
you know I touched his head ok this is a
pretty common conversation for parents
across Canada teaching your kids about
Terry Fox and his attempt to run across
Canada well Brad West is also the mayor
of Fox's hometown he's pushing for Terry
Fox to be put on the $5 bill and says
he's not having any trouble getting
people on board a lot of people are like
that's an absolute no-brainer you know
people people are pretty enthusiastic
about it this coming April will mark 40
years since Terry Fox dipped his
prosthetic leg in the Atlantic Ocean and
hit the road since that day more than
750 million dollars has been collected
for cancer research in his name his
Marathon of Hope grew as he went and it
hasn't stopped
even though cancer cut him down and he
never made it to the Pacific anyway I
could go out there again and finish it I
will now the nominations are pouring
into the Bank of Canada they're listed
on its website 303 and Counting but Port
Coquitlam Fox's hometown is campaigning
to get their guy chosen ya know one
hundred percent agreed on that yeah I
already acted on it Terry is a unifying
choice because he really embodies all
the values that I think all of us no
matter where we live hold dear to our
heart now if there are Terry Fox runs in
every part of the country there are also
supporters all over Eddie Nolan saw Fox
run in Montreal in 1980 he's run every
year since Nolan's also been leaning on
his inspiration recently in his own
battle
cancer he says he'd love to see
Canadians start calling the $5 bill the
Fox oh man
I really am behind this so much a
thousand percent some fans online have
even put up suggestions for what a Fox
fiver could look like there may be other
candidates but none so far seems to have
a campaign behind them public support is
one of the criteria the Bank of Canada
will be considering if it comes down to
popularity that likely makes Terry Fox
well the frontrunner Mike Armstrong
Global News Montreal and that is global
national for this Monday I'm Robin Gill
tonight your Canada is Whitehorse we
would love to see your corner of this
country so email your pictures to
viewers at global national com
thank you for watching and I'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you